how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel there are
certainly a lot of really exciting
things happening in the MCU right now
phase four is right around the corner
with Black Widow coming out in May and
we've even gotten a trailer for three
out of the five Disney Plus shows that
are going to be a part of phase four as
well but outside of the MCU Sony also
has a lot of upcoming exciting projects
that have to do with Marvel characters
we have Morbius coming up that of course
is going to tie directly into spider-man
far from home and of course venom two is
coming out as well but venom 2 possibly
having Spider Man cameo in the movie may
not be his only tie-in to the MCU in
fact it seems like Venom's fate seems to
be tied in to Thor's fate and they're
actually connected by a character who
has been reported to be the main villain
of for love and thunder now for those of
you who may look at the title and say
venom in four four can never happen yes
it can especially with all of the Sony
Marvel deals that have been going on
lately the Sony universe crossing over
into this spider-man universe of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and vice versa
we saw spider-man in the Morbius trailer
and even though it is the Sam Raimi suit
that we see in this photo it does say
murderer over it so it is the same
spider-man from spider-man far from home
and for those of you who may be unaware
the Venom symbiote actually has a deep
history with the Asgardians particularly
with Thor in fact Marvel has already
done the story before in the comics
connecting Thor and venom in a very epic
way so I'll go over the complete story
of Thor and venom and talk about how the
Venom symbiote could end up in Thor love
and thunder in a very real way if we
knew be sure to subscribe to my channel
but notifications turned on for your
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers to understand
how venom could connect to and appear in
Thor love and thunder you have to know
about a character named null null is a
very ancient beam that predates the
birth of the universe not only is he
this ancient beam but he is also the
creator of the very first symbiote and
of course this is a beam that venom has
run into and that Thor has a major
connection to at one point in time Eddie
Brock wants to learn more about the
Venom symbiote and due to some certain
circumstance
he ends up discovering who null is at
one point in time a Clint our dragon
ends up attacking New York City and
venom works together with spider-man the
Miles Morales spider-man to team up and
take it down they then find out that the
dragon is being held captive by shield
who used to experiment with symbiote
soldiers during the Vietnam War
however shield ends up disbanding and
the dragon escapes venom tries to take
it down and it seems like he does but
only temporarily and he finds out that
it's actually a symbiote controlling the
dragon a being called null the god of
the symbiotes it's here where we learned
a little bit about Noel's backstory we
learned that Knoll inhabited the
darkness before the Big Bang and when
the universe did burst into existence
his first act was to kill a celestial
and he succeeded now in this body of the
dead celestial no forged a fire and he
made the form of the first symbiote in
the shape of a blade called the
all-black the extreme heat of the
celestial flame and the noise that the
hammer made beating the blade forging it
into its form and shape are the reasons
why symbiotes today like venom and
carnage are hurt by fire and loud
painful noises so in a sense this is the
origin of their weakness as well
no coded himself and his new symbiote
skin and took his newly forged blade and
carved his way through the light that
invaded his old dark universe and it is
here where the weapon took on a new name
the all-black necro sword also widely
known as the god Slayer sword
now if the all-black nekross sword aka
God Slayer sword sounds familiar it's
because it comes from a Thor villain
Gore now Gore has been reported by some
and is widely anticipated to be the
villain of Thor love and thunder
although nothing is confirmed right now
but this is Thor's connection to the
Venom symbiote and the comic run Thor
god of thunder Thor finds out that some
of the gods are disappearing throughout
the universe so naturally he goes to
investigate why he learns that there is
a being out there that is responsible
for killing these gods and he soon finds
himself face-to-face with gore and when
he finally comes face-to-face with gore
he finds that he has the all-black
nekross sword now Gore has a pretty sad
and tragic story he lost his mother his
father his wife and his children and due
to this he said that the gods must not
be real because if they were real how
could they let this happen
but the race that Gore belonged to were
god-fearing beings who did believe in
the God so when Gore said that he didn't
believe in them they cast him out and
exiled him it's at this point when he is
exiled and leaving his home where null
the god of the symbiotes falls from the
sky it's revealed that nul was in a
battle with a golden god when they both
fell from the heavens towards a planet
with no name as no land this other god
lay on the floor dying Gore comes across
them and he thinks that they're the god
of his world thinking that they're the
gods of his personal world he curses
them for not being there for him and his
family as Noah laid on the floor dying
his symbiote the all-black necro sword
transferred to Gore and gore the god
butcher was born having found out that
the gods were real and didn't actually
help people like himself that needed
help he set out and swore to kill all of
the gods in the universe and that's
where he runs into Thor with the very
first symbiote on his hand the all-black
necro sword and this is how venom could
tie into Thor love and thunder now a few
of these events that happened in the
comics have actually already kind of
happened in the MCU and they're actually
pretty easy to examine for starters
Eddie Brock and the Venom symbiote run
into null when Eddie first wants to
learn more about the symbiote venom and
this is something that is definitely
going to happen most likely in venom 2
and venom the Venom symbiote took Eddie
by surprise as well as it would anybody
who had a random alien attached to them
so it's most likely that Eddie's going
to learn just a little bit more about
venom and where he comes from in venom 2
and perhaps there may even be a little
mention of null then there's the fact
that venom runs into the dragon that noe
was controlling the whole entire time
after shield is no more well right now
in the MCU shield is no more
instead sword has been set up and this
is officially confirmed by the
post-credits scene and spider-man far
from home and not to mention some leaked
photos that we got from the one division
series
now sword stands for sentient world
observation and response department
they're a counterterrorism and
intelligence agency whose main purpose
is to deal with extraterrestrial threats
to the world and it kind of seems like a
bunch of alien symbiotes coming to the
earth threatening the earth would
probably be on their radar
and we know sword is going to be a
pretty big part in the one division
series so perhaps sword could even run
into some symbiotes of n and then
there's the fact that no inhabited the
darkness before the Big Bang then the
Big Bang happened in our universe burst
into existence and this is something
that was actually very specifically
mentioned in guardians of the galaxy the
collector talks about before the
universe existed there were
singularities and then the universe
burst into existence and these
singularities transferred over to our
new universe mostly being the Infinity
stones iation itself there were six
singularities exploded into existence
and the remnants of these systems were
forged into concentrated ingots this is
exactly how Knoll came into existence in
the new universe so perhaps in the MCU
maybe more than six singularities moved
over to the new universe and this is how
he could have came into our universe but
remember the first thing that he did
when he came to our universe he killed a
celestial he then formed the all-black
necro sword and first symbiote inside of
this celestial well we have seen the
dismembered head of a celestial in
guardians of the galaxy that head is
actually referred to as the place know
where this celestial God had to die
somehow somebody would have had to cut
its head off could it be possible that
it was null could this be the celestial
that he first killed when he entered the
main universe that the MCU existed from
here inside of the celestial he would
Forge the all-black necro sword and once
he made the sword from there he would
cut through the light that entered his
dimension possibly cutting the head of
the celestial which ends up being
nowhere at the same time then eventually
going on to fight other gods in this
newly formed universe until eventually
fighting the golden God from there he
would fight to a standstill with this
God and fall on a planet and this planet
would be a planet that Gore the god
killer would be on where he would
receive the symbiote and the all-black
necro sword and from there Gore would go
on to hunt gods and if that is indeed
what has happened in the MCU then Gore
is definitely going to be running into
Thor and probably soon and this is how
the Venom symbiote could can
to Thor love and thunder and it's even
possible that we could see that very
first symbiote the all-black neck
ressort appear in the movie as well
currently there are rumors and reports
stating that gore is indeed going to be
the main villain of Thor love and
thunder and it's even been said that
Christian Bale because we know that he's
been cast for a role in the movie is
going to be playing Gore it makes
perfect sense because Christian Bale has
already stated that he doesn't want to
come on to do a movie that he's going to
have to play a character for three four
or five different movies and it's been
stated that he's going to be the villain
of the movie and as much as we would
love for him to be beta ray bill Adam
warlock or the Silver Surfer it seems
like those characters are going to be in
the MCU for at least one or two films so
gore is the most likely option that
Marvel's going to go with and if that
ends up being the case and he does
possess the all-black necro sword then a
symbiote will definitely be in Thor at
love and thunder and depending on a deal
that Sony and Marvel could work out they
could tie this directly in with venom
Marvel and Sony know that a lot of
people want to see venom in the MCU
especially if they are planning for the
sinister six to be a part of the MCU it
would be foolish not to use venom for
this storyline
so as you can see it's very possible and
quite easy to tie venom and the
symbiotes into Thor love and thunder and
it seems like the MCU could have
possibly been setting this up for a
pretty long time now but let me know
what you think about this would you like
to see the all-black necro sword and
first symbiote be in for at love and
thunder and have a connection to venom
leave your thoughts about this and the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay
up-to-date on everything relating to the
MCU as you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof